The United States authorized Pfizer's pill to fight COVID,...
...making it the first oral at-home treatment for the coronavirus...
...in what doctors hope is an important tool in the fight...
...against the fast-spreading Omicron variant.
Pfizer's antiviral regimen...
...was 90% effective in preventing hospitalizations and deaths in patients...
...at high risk of severe illness,...
...and recent lab data suggests the drug retains its effectiveness against Omicron.
The Food and Drug Administration's decision to issue emergency authorization...
...for the treatment comes as the U.S. combats a surge in COVID-19 cases...
...driven by the Omicron variant.
The most widely-used monoclonal antibody treatments for COVID-19,...
...which are typically given intravenously in hospitals,...
...have proven to be less effective at fighting the variant...
...and doctors told Reuters...
...there is limited supply of the one remaining treatment that works.
The hope is that the Pfizer pill fills the gap.
Pfizer said it is ready to start immediate delivery in the U.S....
...and raised its production projections to 120 million courses of treatment in 2022.